[Music]
it's been known for a few months now
that zack snyder will be releasing his
fabled cut version of justice league one
special new feature
this time jarelido can actually be seen
as the joker in front of the camera
it is considered unlikely that he will
be given a major role but due to the new
images fans can at least catch a first
glimpse
it is noticeable that the joker in
contrast to his appearance in suicide
squad no longer has
tattoos instead he now wears a hospital
gown in a surgical mask
which is a hint to joker's escape is
neither confirmed to vanity fair
we took the time to colorize the black
and white shots so that you can get a
better impression beforehand
in addition the 54 year old director
revealed that the joker is going to wear
bulletproof
west with police badges as trophies in
other scenes
without wanting to reveal too much the
new look could be related to the keyword
nightmare fans of bad members superman
will know exactly what we mean by that
the 4-hour long blockbuster will be
released on march 18th
on hbo max in the united states you can
watch the brand new trailer on the
website kinochak.com as of february 14th
last week tom holland spelled some news
about his upcoming movies again
in a conversation with the variety award
circuit podcast the 24 year old talked
about his latest adventure
uncharted where he will portray the
young nathan drake there was one
statement that did come as a surprise as
holland shared that the action sequences
in the video game adaption were the
biggest he's ever been part of
he went on saying it was absurd how many
bruce's cuts and punches he had
sustained while
filming this in itself is of course very
good news after all all fans are hoping
for a successful and
action-packed film adoption still the
question is whether this is a classic
case of tom holland's often very
enthusiastic spirit or
whether uncharted is really going to be
more action-packed than avengers and
game
on the other hand he could also have
meant that the real action on set is
simply greater because while
end game naturally shows off cgi to its
best advantage
there could simply be more real action
scenes and uncharted
either way it has definitely fueled
speculation among fans making the
anticipation for the february 11th 2022
release date
all the greater the young brit also has
some information on the upcoming
spider-man 3
and it too comes as a surprise for
several weeks the rumor has persisted
that we will get to see
three spider-man in the new movie tom
holland andrew garfield and toby maguire
this could be made possible by a
multiverse that could run like a common
thread through phase four
in an interview with esquire though
holland makes it clear that he knows
absolutely nothing about this and that
marvel hasn't given him any information
about it yet with his comment he's
heating up the speculations as well
after all filming has already been going
on for about eight weeks
so there are three possibilities either
he's bluffing pretty convincingly
or he's telling the truth and we won't
see maguire and garfield in the third
part
or marvel is withholding the information
from him as long as they can so that he
doesn't spill the beans again
it all seems fairly possible however in
terms of all the rumors circulating
so far it's unlikely that garfield
maguire won't be in it
what do you think feel free to write it
down in the comments the release date of
spider-man 3 is on december 17
2021 a few days ago disney announced to
close down
the once very successful blue sky
studios
known for animated films like ice age
horton here's a who
and rio the studio once brought its
parent company billions in revenue
but now things are to come to an end as
deadline
magazine reports the ongoing pandemic
has made it no longer profitable for
disney to keep the studio in business
quite tragic not only for nostalgics and
fans of the ice age films but above all
for the nearly 450 employees who will be
without a job as of april
for disney this is presumably not a bad
decision since the parent company still
has two animation studios at its
disposal
however it remains unclear how projects
that have already been started will be
dealt with as for example an
ice age series for disney plus as well
as the movie nimona about a young
shapeshifter had been planned while the
latter has been cancelled
the ice age series could still be
tackled by a different studio
nevertheless disney should not lack new
content due to the closure of the studio
since disney plus can hardly keep up
with a number
of new projects at the moment in the
gaming world the video game the last of
us is definitely one of the best of its
kind
the game development naughty dog has
created a true masterpiece particularly
with the first part which is on par with
many movies story-wise if not better the
second part is heavily debated within
the gaming community due to its
storyline but was nevertheless able to
win more than 260 game of the year
awards last year
naturally this makes the upcoming series
about joel and ellie all the most
subject to criticism and presents
chernobyl creator and showrunner craig
mason with a major challenge
as deadline reports the official casting
of the two main character has finally
been announced
the grumpy joel will be played by pedro
pascal while the young ally will be
played by
balor ramsey the emotional story is
strongly based on the plot of the video
game
and to the delight of many fans does not
break new ground like the uncharted film
adaption does
sadly it is not yet clear when we will
be able to see joles and ellie's
adventures in the fungus infested world
of
clickers and runners lucasfilm announced
the firing of gina carano in a statement
last wednesday
it is said that they no longer plan to
work with her in the future as her
social media posts
denigrate other people based on their
cultural or religious identity
this is in part due to tweets that
polemically criticized the us
government's action to contain the
pandemic and in support of allegations
of election fraud following the u.s
presidential election last november the
peak however was undoubtedly
an instagram post in which she compared
the rejection of questionable political
positions to the persecution of jews
during world war ii
which she deleted following a shitstorm
as a consequence the hashtag via gina
carano trended which for disney was then
probably
the final straw to break the camel's
back the whole thing is particularly
unfortunate for herol as kara dune in
the mandalorian who played no small part
in the first two seasons and was also
planned for season 3
and the spin-off ranges of the new
republic whether her character
will now be completely dropped or
whether recasting would perhaps make
more sense
will probably be decided in the coming
days the third season of the mandalorian
will be shot as of april 5th
and is scheduled to appear on disney
plus in early 2022 at
the latest
you